نفايات المواد الخطيره في اسرائيل تمتاز
بخصائص طبيعيه وكيميائيه وبيولوجيه تضر
بالانسان والبيئه حسب التقرير الوارد من
وزاره حمايه البيئه الاسرائيليه تنتج
اسرائيل
317 الف طن سنويا من النفايات الخطيره
لكنها تعالج 40% منها فقط بالتدوير
تواصلنا مع وزاره حمايه البيئه
الاسرائيليه لاجراء مقابله حول مصير
الستين بالمئه المتبقيه كان الرد ان علينا
التواصل مع الاداره المدنيه الاسرائيليه
التي هي الجهه المسموح لها بالحديث عن
الموضوع
بدورنا حاولنا التواصل مع اكثر من جهه في
الاداره المدنيه الاسرائيليه
لم نجد منهم ان يرت
ولمعرفه ما يقول الطرف الاسرائيلي في كل
ما سبق توجهنا الى بلديه معاليه دوميم
الاسرائيليه المحاذيه لمكب نفايات العبدلي
حيث التقينا الدكتور نيتشيان ليفي مدير
عام المنتدى الاسرائيلي للاداره البيئيه
في اسرائيل للحديث عن تلك المكرمه الصحيه
واثارها على البيئه والانسان اسبابها ومن
المسؤول وما الحل لكل ذلك
في البدايه يجب ان نتعاون التعاون مهم
للغايه ضع جانبا القضايا السياسيه لدينا
مساله صحيه هنا لذلك علينا ان نفعل كل ما
بوسعنا من اجل صحه الناس لا نريد ان يموت
الناس بالسرطان ولا نريد ان يموت الناس من
امراض الجهاز التنفسي لذا فلنضع قضايا
سياسيه جانبا ولنتعاون من اجل شعبنا ايضا
[موسيقى]
البعوضه تعضك اذا كنت فلسطينيا او
اسرائيليا تلوث الهواء لا يفرق بين
الرئتين كما تعلم سيؤذي الجميع لا تذهب اي
من نفايات اسرائيل الى الضفه الغربيه
باستثناء القليل جدا لذا ليس كثيرا نحن
نتحدث في اسرائيل عن حوالي خمسه ملايين طن
سنويا من النفايات ربما يذهب 1% الى الضفه
الغربيه ربما انا لا اعرف
60% من النفايات تذهب الى مكبات في مواقع
خاضعه للتنظيم في اسرائيل وهناك موقع واحد
في الضفه الغربيه ويوجد واحد في وادي
الاردن وجميع ما تبقى منها مغلق وسيجري
اعاده تاهيله في القريب العاجل وامر ذلك